quick tour update gang the state trashy
tour is a cook and we're adding shows
and we're coming to a city near you
bring the squad out and come see us
we're in New Haven Connecticut
Burlington Vermont new second shows
added in both those cities what then
we're going to Tampa Florida second show
added there Dania Beach Florida Raleigh
North Carolina Louisville Cleveland get
your tickies now you snooze you lose see
you out there welcome to another
exciting edition of are you garbage the
show where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's new favorite podcast this
is are you garbage oh yeah it's that
little show we sit down with your
favorite comedians and we find that if
they're good to be classy or to just a
big old piece of trash I'm your host
Dave trolley coming at you on a
beautiful day out back here in the new
edition Tony spending that cut still I
know saw this morning she had dollar
bills all over her back I don't know
what she was doing upstairs in the
bedroom but it wasn't PG I can tell you
that my co-host is coming at you from
right next to me he is the CEO of Ru
garbage he is an international
businessman he's got the guys on Wall
Street nervous and the guys on Main
Street all rooting for him give it up
for KJ Kevin James Ryan what's up
everybody thanks for tuning in as always
please make sure you rate you subscribe
on iTunes full video of album on YouTube
as you know those numbers are
cooking then obviously I'll have to say
to this room the greatest gosh darn
website of all time
www.patreon.com gang check it out it's
the best website in the world is and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works to ones
Works to twos the threes and fours he
crosses the t's and he dots the eyes now
you get a little peek at him with the
Toby cam give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Tommy McMullen everybody what
up dude
oh man the exchange rate on this guy we
got in here we got some top dollars
garbage from across the bond dude shout
out the lids let's go heavy hitter in
the building ladies and gentlemen kids
holding up the Western Front
setting it up in the European theater
gang we couldn't be more excited to have
our incredibly and I mean incredibly
special guest back with us again today
if you haven't caught his episode do
yourself a favor and go check it out he
is a very funny very successful stand-up
comedian and podcaster he just released
not one but two stand-up specials this
year alone about to kick off a new tour
and of course he is the host of have
award give it up for Adam role
not to be in the new guy [__] sharp
kid what's up wearing that money well
I'm so jealous of everyone's ability in
this room particularly yours to just
with without missing a beat
flawlessly broadcast like a monologue
that you've improvised he loves it it's
absolutely he's the best in the best
best In The Biz I'm drunk
I got about 10 minutes in me I'll be
sleeping in a minute hey can I get him
one of them white claws keep them awake
brother congratulations man thanks for
having us back yeah dude yeah it's uh
things are going well over the other
side and I like to pop over here every
now and then
sounds like you're coming from another
dimension
over here cleaning space money
the one thing I do love about you like I
guess it's I guess it's the the English
thing is you look you look you're very
well put together sharp yeah you think
so yeah where's that shirt where's that
jacket from so this is from a shop in
Liverpool uh called tazuti so they're
like a chain of um they sell like
designer [__] but like if you go in at
the right time it's one of those places
where they sell designer stuff and if
you go in when it first gets released
like this will be like
but then like three weeks later no one's
boss or whatever but this was like 80
off all right I'll give you that like
it's really so you're still a dirtbag
yeah like I'm quite liberal with me
money but I'd rather buy five things
sure so I'll wait until it comes down a
little bit you know what I mean I
thought you meant if you're sneaking at
the right time when the guy's grabbing
his lunch yeah it's gonna walk out with
a five finger discount
Ah that's awesome has there been any
because we're obviously you know bad
with money has there been any stupid
purchases anything you regret you were
doing well when you came over the first
time now you guys are really blown it
out so the last time I was here as we
were sort of discussing before we came
on was a bit of a [__] trip for me and I
had a bad time over here break up with a
girl and stuff and when I went back I
thought I was handling everything really
well and when I looked back on it I was
having a very glamorous mental breakdown
yeah so I got myself like a city like in
Liverpool we've got the the most uh sort
of uh
sauce after area is the docks like the
Albert dock in Liverpool okay I got
myself like a what a [__]
by the docks
[Applause]
it's a nice look
like
like it look it's red it's not gray it's
it's it's frizzy it looks good
one day we'll have enough money to live
by the refiner yeah
it sounds nice
when my number comes in I'm moving right
to the train tracks
don't get low you just meet a guy and
you're like you're my kind of guy I love
it so you were living over there so I I
was I was living in a suburb and I just
went [__] this I'm gonna go and live in
the city center sure on the docks Flex
uh high-rise Apartments three bedrooms I
live on my own
I've got a bedroom that's exclusively
for sneakers like it's just it's
wall-to-wall trainers
um and I did that and then I I bought a
car so and you messaged me when I got it
I bought a Range Rover Velar yeah and
it's [__] great automatic and that's
like standing in the UK it was just uh
it's a it's a few months where I look
back and go I I can miss a mix after two
years in an apartment that tripled my
rent and I should have probably just
bought a house put a little bit away
yeah I went and got drunk or something
I saved yourself a couple of a couple of
quid he's over there buying cruise ships
[__] it all right that's what I'm
talking about yeah
ah but like actual like just buying
stuff I I'm I'm quite bad for that yeah
if I see something I'll just definitely
want it yeah we're completing it yeah
yeah why did that when I didn't have a I
would have like 80 bucks in my account I
would go spend 50 at the bar like I'm
just bad with money I'm just horrible
with it so it's funny though it was
always it always worked itself out yeah
because I didn't I didn't pay my student
loans I didn't pay my [__] credit
card bills my my cable would get shut
off it worked itself out yeah so me and
my best friend who's he's our Toby he's
our producer on the podcast name is Carl
he's uh when he got into University
neither of us went to University that
year he got his student loan mine I can
come through yeah so I didn't get mine
so he had a student loan that he had
absolutely no need for so between me and
him we spent every penny of it going out
seven nights a week like six months so
he he's got like two because eventually
he went back to University and got more
student loans and he's got two student
loan debts wait they gave me the money
and you weren't you weren't rolling
school and you guys just kept the cash
they gave even the student loan and then
like a week or two in he was like I
don't want to do this course so I'm just
going to [__] leave you've got the
debt but they don't take the money off
you yeah all right that's all right
yeah right then a round of beers after
the 20 years ends up costing you like 18
000 in interest payments
[__] up for six months good good six
months yeah splitting it with this boy
that's all right right there you get an
A in a friendship my friend I'll tell
you that right now oh that's [__] so
I love that I actually so I ended up
owing him hundreds and hundreds of
pounds because he wasn't just giving me
he was like right well we'll go out
tonight and I'll give you another
hundred out of this sure
um I when my mum so like we were talking
before we started the last time I was on
here there's a line that I get tweeted a
lot from this of course funniest
episodes the ale talker yes my mom was
an alcoholic and that's what killed her
when she died I got left like 2 000
pounds because she was
[Laughter]
and when I got it that's when I paid
Carl back and he he was like I'm I'd
rather you give me it in 10 years yeah I
can't take your mom's last two thousand
dollars
I don't want this money give me any
other money with this money and I made
him that money's haunted man yeah
[__] it you'll get bad juju on you you
spend that money that's bad I use my
alcoholic mums inheritance to pay off an
alcohol bit
shut up
and the upside down in the fish and
chips
oh man that is [__] so funny that's
great what uh what have you done since
you've been here have you soaked in any
of the sights and he probably see a
Broadway show you hit any landmarks show
I'm a big musical theater
yeah I went to see Hamilton a few years
ago I'm just like this is great
um so I went to see parade the other
night I don't even know it's really good
it's like a a Resurgence of an old one
that's okay and uh Ben Platts the lead
so he was the guy the original dear Evan
Hansen he's gone on to do a lot of stuff
in like movies and stuff and it was like
it's hard to get a ticket it was like
one ticket left the single and luckily
I'm on my own I'll tell you so I was
like I'll just take it back and I went
to see that I went to a hockey game went
to the Rangers against the Penguins
there you go MSG wow really good game
and I've just
Ace of good places I went to cats late
last night and got the pastrami I went
over to Brooklyn got uh to sweet chick
got some chicken and waffles I I went
around to Freeman's had a steak eggs and
fries at 9 30 a.m because I texted to my
girlfriend and I was like hey I'm having
this she was like isn't it half nine I
was like it's what they do here these
Americans are nuts I don't know what to
tell you hey babe I don't make the rules
you know what I'm saying that's all
right did you fly over here up front I
did fly over here but I'm flying back in
the back hold on a second wait that's a
dirtbag
it was cheaper to upgrade on the way out
so it was like 350 pounds to upgrade on
the way out and I was like that's worth
it on the way back it was like four and
a half Grand oh yeah that's [__]
white yeah it's just not I can't I can't
justify that in my own yeah yeah it's
funny though give me first class going
that is true
13 pounds heavier and sweaty try to
explain as a flight attendant I was up
front over there
do you know what it is on the way out I
flew it like noon so no one needed a bed
and that's why there was so much like
the cheapest upgrade on the way back I'm
flying at night everyone wants to sleep
on the plane sure okay that makes sense
I'll give you the price difference I'll
give you that
um yeah what I'll do is I'll just
because even I've got premium economy
okay you still get all your drinks and
some decent food
um as decent as airplane food can make
sure so I will just get hammered so that
I can sleep sure sure will you get drunk
at the airport yeah and then on the
plane
until I just cannot see and then I'll
just I'll sleep sometimes they slow your
roll on the planes though I noticed like
they give you they give you a drink when
you get on but then you gotta wait till
you get up to the cruising altitude
before they they reload you yeah usually
by then I'm running out of steam you
just buy some cans in the airport and
take them on with you in your hand
luggage
I think that's illegal that's for sure
against FAA regulations I don't know
what users are doing over there but like
it is against the rules but what they do
is they go say you can't drink your own
I'll call on the plane and you just go
oh well I'll I'll make this my last one
I'm it's already open like what are you
actually gonna do
you're a smooth talker though I wouldn't
Panic I'd be waiting for the air marshal
to [__] tie me up I I got a bottle of
Jameson I'm quite happy to always argue
with people in like customer service
roles because really yeah because a lot
of the time they don't know why they're
enforce the rule so I was in a hotel in
London
a couple of weeks ago and the hotel
bulldog
the hotel's got like a really good hotel
bar and like a restaurant to it love a
hotel bar very nice hotel bars but it's
what it's the type where people would go
to that bar even if they're not
residents in the hotel right it's called
the hoxton it's in shoreditch okay and
uh so I I woke up like really hungover
from we went to countries to Country
Music Festival
um the country music festival in London
uh went with my girlfriend and her
friend and her friends uh country music
like American country music yeah yeah no
kids so Zac Brown man with the
headliners
they were great and the next one I woke
up really hungover so I put my shorts on
and a t-shirt but I'm in the hotel so I
didn't want to put I didn't have like uh
my sliders or flip-flops with me so I
just went down Barefoot I was like it's
all right I'm on this customer service
agent side and I got to the bar and I
went could I just have a two pints of uh
Coke please and then the guy who's like
the major deal whatever comes over and
goes uh I can't save you with no shoes
on and I was like why
and he goes because you can't be in the
restaurant with no shoes on and I was
like but I'm already like I won't come
back
I learned my lesson just give me my
Cooks I can't say yeah I was like well
I'm not leaving without two Coke Jesus
because this guy's not what you're gonna
do is you're gonna make me walk where
I'm gonna walk anyway if you give me the
coats right I go upstairs and get shoes
to come back and all the cokes and walk
back with me why why are we [__]
doing this you've told me the rules that
I didn't [__] know and why would I
know it I'm just in a hotel I'm hungover
I'm probably still drunk get me two
Cokes and I'll be out of your way and
you'll be able to mine sounds like you
were for sure still drunk by the way
of course he did because he he knew he
doesn't want a barefoot guy in his bar
and he knew the only ways to stop that
happening was to give me the cokes his
policy has to go out the window [__]
this he probably thought you were a
homeless dude
he had a homeless guy in here singing
Zac Brown lyrics
oh man that's all right damn God all
right well I'm glad to hear things are
going well
Ah that's good stuff it is amazing that
you guys did a show in an arena and then
you're Barefoot screaming I know
that's crazy
I just feel there's been like this whole
flip I think covert sort of accelerated
as well it used to be the customer is
always right and in the past decade no
you're everybody's yeah you're wrong
it's completely flipped to the the work
has always right because everyone's
getting paid [__] all to do these jobs
yeah yeah like people feel sorry for
these people which is absolutely the
right way to be sure and in the majority
of things if someone's being a dick for
no reason you should be on the side of
the server who's on like three four five
six seven eight pounds an hour of course
because it's not fair but when they're
just deciding to take their day out on
me because it's eight o'clock in the
morning and he's in work and he can see
that I had a better night than he did
[__]
that's pretty bulletproof dude
I like how you put yourself on the side
of the Working Man yeah but then you're
like I walk into a restaurant with no
pants on
it's like come on
you know I have a better night
he could just say that like I'm so
miserable now that like because
hangovers are like I think there's like
a it's like Newton's Cradle like the
worst you look the better you were
having it sure yes yeah yeah and I look
like [__] so he knew that last night I
had had a good time and I think he was
jealous of it and I think that's why he
wanted to this game must be a
billionaire
look how bad he looks this guy must be
worth a lot of money
what the [__] Cradle by the way Newton's
Cradle is the the
um the dangling metal balls and if you
click it for every action there's a
reaction is that what that's called yeah
I always just thought it was a thing on
my uncle's desk
I thought that was the name of it
[Laughter]
I just love [__] with those things
all right all right let's uh let's
settle here a little bit
um guys uh as you know when you sign up
for patreon we will answer your patreon
patreon question on air your garbage
question it's just the best way to do it
uh patreon gets first crack at it and we
got some heat it's tough to try to
tailor it to I'm not that well versed in
uh you know in British culture because
we we have a lot of American dirt bags
but I'm curious to see here's to see the
crossover here
um this is from rwm is there currently
any tape on any remote controls in your
house no but there is like missing box
that I just I've just got like exposed
battery that's that's not good that's
this is gonna sound dumb are your
batteries the same as ours no that's
[__] huge
you want like my TV remote to the size
of this table
[Laughter]
I don't know their plugs are real weird
what the hell's going on no [__] that
you think ours are no plugs in America
are [__] terrible they don't stay in
the [__] wall oh yeah like the ones
in the UK
[Laughter]
but yours are monstrous yeah but they
stay in the [__] wall
they only do have one purpose and that's
to stay in the wall I always think I'm
about to juice up Frankenstein with
these things I use a hairdryer because
like if I just let this dry it's just
fun yeah keep the quaff so I have to I
have to use it for the quiff like the
Swift okay yeah if you bring your hair
dryer with you will use the one in the
hotel I use I always bring the one with
me because if you I don't know whether
you've experienced a hotel hair dryers I
have it's like having an asthmatic child
breathe on you like yeah some of them
are great you smell that hair to
somebody else's burning air
but yes like I've been drying my hair in
the hotel over here and I've had to like
plug it back in like three or four times
because it's just coming out the [__]
wall yeah plugs are built to keep the
thing that you're using in the [__]
wall and your plugs don't keep anything
in the [__] wall all right all right
I think isn't it because they were like
there wasn't air travel they're like
you're never gonna like they made it
differently knowingly I think
they were like oh well the Europe has
these and they were like owl
you're not gonna be taking your toaster
to Europe like it's whatever just who
gives a [__]
I think that's what it was Mainland
Europe has different ones again what
yeah what about my wife's German she had
this it's different than you get
everything on the same guy very close
looking though isn't it it's it's closer
than the states closer than the states
yeah I don't care which one we use it
should all be on the same page we should
all be all driving on the same side of
the road we should all be using I guess
the metric system right that's the
smartest ones the smarter one I believe
yeah and I'll use the same plugs what's
going on we can't change it now why not
it'd be [__] you have to replace all
these goddamn cables in here only
another 50 Grand you're nuts are the
batteries different
they're the same exactly the same really
you're gonna be fine over there you have
Double A's and Triple A's and all that
stuff yeah use the same thing yeah see
there you go we come together and they
got chocolate and everything really oh
yeah I think I know about British
chocolate what are you [__] nuts oh
chocolate's better than the American
chocolate
I don't disagree with that I uh the
sugar I don't agree with that but I
don't just I don't I don't disagree with
it I like a Cadbury yeah oh companies
Cadbury's all right and if you ever go
to Ireland
uh there's a red like it cost you a lot
for like a small bar they've got the
original recipe cadburys well it's like
really expensive and it's even better
bam but Cadbury is yes she's going to
Ireland this weekend
big man's got to get his handles on the
pure I do like a Toblerone like a tuber
loan yeah there are Swiss no put that a
bit like or German it's hard for me to
decide to buy one because I know it's
just a challenge for me Joe like really
hard like yeah the triangle's weird yeah
I'm about it though yeah do love a cat
man you have the Cadbury Cream Eggs over
there too I don't like the cream eggs it
gives me like a weird feeling at the
back of me throws huh I thought that was
something they pushed on the Americans
now that that the riffraff have it
they're quite common especially around
Easter sure yeah they're all right yeah
Karma once again a couple years ago they
did like um full-size Easter eggs full
of the cream oh that's too much yeah
that's all right
yikes okay let's talk about a ladder
talk about leaving bozos holding the bag
do yourself a favor gang get over there
and get a little therm life insurance so
you're not getting buried in a cooler in
the backyard which is probably where I'm
gonna end up couple of [__] 7-Eleven
flowers on that great
but gang do yourself a favor ladder is
easy no doctors no needles you get up to
what three million in coverage I believe
so much yeah gang you find out if you're
instantly approved uh for immediate
peace of mind you just need a few
minutes you need a phone or a laptop to
apply like the big man said 100 digital
no needles just a couple questions about
your health and uh you feel confident
prepared for when the unthinkable
happens they got a 4.8 4.8 out of 5 star
rating on trust pilot and the best place
on the Forbes best life insurance list
in 2021 you'll be in great hands baby so
go to ladderlife.com garbage a day to
see if you're instantly approved that's
ladder
l-a-d-d-e-r-life.com garbage
ladderlife.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about factor factor factor factor
let's talk about knocking down two three
four of those no
but they're that good they're that
delicious they're fantastic throw them
in a microwave they're ready in two
minutes oh absolutely delicious that are
you bozos like to put them on a skillet
and do it nice side though cause I'm a
goddamn gentleman yeah I signed on a
factory sorry to cut you off no I sound
on a factor way before they were an uh a
sponsor it's just Kismet told us about
him because his brother no this was all
me really he used something else this
was all me I found factor I signed up
about a year ago and they've been
they're fantastic they keep you a little
trim make they take the decision making
out for you know what I mean if you're
keto you're vegan you're vegetarian
looking for something protein packed or
just counting your calories which I'm
trying to do Factor has a meal plan
specifically suited for your needs so
you can look and feel your best they got
34 dietitian approved weekly option
there's always something new to try and
gang you go on there you figure out what
you want you can pause it you can cancel
it head to factor meals.com garbage50
and use code garbage 50 to get 50 off
your first box that's code garbage 50 at
factormeals.com
garbage50 to get 50 off your first box
look at that thank you to facta for
sponsoring today today's episode
um okay this one's from you down with
fix same same we're in the remote world
how many remotes do you need to turn the
TV on at your house do you have them
programmed as one or you jumping all
over the place no it's so I've got uh I
I primarily use the TV in the bedroom
now okay and it's one but it does
[__] everything it's got Netflix it's
got Apple TV Amazon and they've all got
their own buttons on the remote and will
you lay in bed will you sit in bed and
watch TV yeah yeah [__] flat screen
right yeah yeah right and he bought it
maybe like three or four months ago and
then I've got a very similar thing in
the living room uh but that TV is a
couple of years older so I have my Xbox
plugged into that and the Xbox does a
lot of the apps gotcha that's the bypass
will you eat in the bedroom
yeah but really really like if I'm
watching depends what mood I mean
sometimes if like I like like the NFL so
if I'm and they're shown really late in
the UK so if I'm up like late after a
show I'll watch that in bed with like
some food I've brought back after the
show sure but like if I'm having like my
dinner then everywhere
sitting there cutting a steak [__] I
don't hate that with the NFL because my
girls from Hawaii and when we go over
there they're real early in the morning
yeah which isn't too bad either just
something different it's nice but late
night NFL that's all right but the bars
are usually closed down by then right
you have to watch it at the house no our
bars especially in Liverpool so people
don't know this Liverpool as far as I'm
concerned and obviously I am biased is
the best city in the UK New York is a
lot more similar to Liverpool than it is
to London okay
um you can get a drink in Liverpool 24
hours a day at a bar what that's pretty
cool like the maybe like an hour or two
where you can't where like it shuts at
7am but then by 9 A.M everywhere else is
back breakfast and stuff I didn't know
that I have everything shut down around
11. no oh no no no no no like if I was
going on a big night out with my friends
we probably wouldn't be in a bar to 11.
no [__] we'd probably pre-drink until
10. did the bars over there get a good
crowd for the football games and all
that stuff
um you mean for like American football
yeah uh not for the Super Bowl yeah you
have to like buy tickets for the Super
Bowl okay everybody'll be like we're
showing the Super Bowl and you'll buy
tickets in advance because people want
to go and see it and they make a night
of it sure
um for a big Liverpool game it's
probably crazy it's [__] insane it's
nuts you're a Liverpool you're a
Liverpool fan right die hard yeah yeah I
I see you post pictures at the games I'm
like I want to get if I want I want to
go I want to go to a game a Liverpool
game with you yeah good time I'll tell
you oh yeah I'll take you it seems like
what are those stadiums hold uh oz so
Liverpool's at the minute is 56. okay
and before the start of next season it
will have been increased to 61 because
they're adding 5 000 new seats so my
favorite thing about football in the UK
is the songs are they passing out sheet
music how are you guys learning these
songs dude you just learn it like if
there's a new one yeah like the so our
main
like home fans so there's obviously four
stands you've got the main stand which
is quite quiet there's a lot of tourists
there you've got the stand opposite that
which is the the Kenny dalglish stand
he's one of our greatest ever players to
stand the named after him again there's
less tourists there but it's a similar
sort of vibe the the anfield road end is
where the away fans sit and there's a
lot of like R given there but the main
sort of Die Hard fans is called the cop
that's our main stand and if there's a
new song the cop will just sing it
like 20 times in the first like two
three games that it becomes a song and
by the end of it you just know it yeah
like the core fan groups who know the
songs from immediately and also the
internet's helping that now because like
the most recent song that came out last
year is they're all like parodies of
like famous songs so there's a
um
there's a Beatles song called I feel
fine
um my baby's good to me you know she
buys me diamond rings you know she said
so I'm in love with her and I feel fine
I got you so the the on manager yeah
did the whole thing started from the
beginning the song and dance man he said
he liked the theater didn't just hit the
chorus you got like a person there but
this guy's show it off oh manager Jurgen
klopp his song is a parody of that okay
so it's Jurgen said to me you know we'll
win the Premier League you know he said
so I'm in love with him and I feel fine
that's true I'm so glad that jagen is a
red I'm so glad he delivered what he
said yeah again said to me you know I
just picture yourself now I just
pictured three guys somewhere and
crippled [__] drunk trying to figure
out those words to line them up so I
will show you it I won't get it up now
because obviously we're recording but as
soon as we finish I will show you that
is how that sounds started so that is
maybe eight drunk liver podlins in a pub
in Benfica what rhymes with wind
sitting here but they're just hammered
just [__] yeah that's [__] great
see that part is so fun it's such a
shame the Tucker is so goddamn boring I
love it
yeah take that from this kid
um obviously not now you're a high
profile guy but as a younger man did you
ever mix it up with the games
no I nearly got into a fight uh against
Leeds but it was a because of a comment
one of my friends made so Leeds in
Liverpool they don't hate each other but
they also don't like each other and we
were leaving the the stadium and to get
to where our coach was to get home you
had to walk maybe like 15-20 minutes and
while we're on that walk we're getting
towards our coaches one of my friends
when Leeds is a [__] I'm never
coming back
and then behind us there was maybe like
30 40 leads fans who heard it yikes and
we've just got really really lucky we
were unlucky and lucky I think I think
you told us about this that's right okay
yeah so they um they were looking for a
fight with fans who wanted a fight we
just we were essentially we were in the
Gaza Strip like we we just accidentally
walked right along the tightrope sure
yeah yeah we got out the way and it all
kicked off ah there you go gentlemen
take us back to the docks now sir
with my many remote controls
and my huge batteries uh this one's from
Billy ten dollar new homie never have
one red is it garbage to save your beer
can so you can recycle them to buy more
beer
I do you guys what's your recycling
situation because I know the Germans
save all their bottles and go return
them for the deposit oh we don't do that
you don't do that we just like so we got
two different colors so they just Chuck
them with leads fans
this place is a [__] I'm out of here
they have to watch Outdoors to do any
damage we freeze them and show them and
throw them at the other team yeah
there's two different color bins ones
for General waste ones for recycling
gotcha we don't get any money to recycle
what about like the homeless people they
don't come around and get they don't
recycle them no
they go in the regular trash
okay you're on your own buddy he's quick
and he's quick so there's no program
where if you return the bottles or cans
you get money uh no very few anyway like
there's a guy who delivers
um like soda on a van streets of Street
and he gives you like 20 pence back if
you've attend the big box that's a big
glass bottle
um damn you still have that over there
yeah oh that's probably good soda oh
it's [__] great it's the best real
it's like the brand is it just is it
Coke or whatever is it oh no no like
it's like some local uh I think it's
called daler d-a-y-l-a that's the name
of the company Okay and like the cream
soda's bright green like toxic looking
[__] absolutely yeah uh dandelion and
Burdock and iron brew and orange Aid and
Cherry Aid and it's great Ah that's what
I'm talking about that's all right it's
[__] amazing yeah yeah it tastes like
bubble gum dude yeah as well really good
for a hangover
um I don't think I've ever even had it I
was only I've only been England once for
two days
I was drunk for most of it it's pretty
good I am Brew comes from Scotland
gotcha and oh that's right you spent
time in Scotland so Coca-Cola is the
number one soft drink in every country
in the world [__] forget about it
that it's sold in apart from Scotland
which is beaten by Iron Brew
keep it old school you're gonna get some
for the set I gotta test some of this
stuff can you get it here you could
probably get it here it's any sort of
Specialties yeah it pops up every now
and again if you want Homeland Security
crawling up your ass
[Laughter]
oh for a little cream soda I'm all about
it that's good stuff uh all right let's
see this one's from Tommy hi you just
says yo how long do you keep the film on
the TV screen
if you buy a TV it comes with like the
thin plastic or a phone I even turn it
on really yeah that's the best feeling
in the world like you're buying a brand
new TV because you want it like sure the
top end 4K 8K yeah I'm gonna put on a
[__]
film over this like what keep it on your
phone too no I was just describing the
film that I was talking about okay now I
also take it off I don't think I take it
off before I turn it on
I don't know though but I love that
feeling oh I love the feeling as well oh
it's up there will you save the box to
an expensive electronic like a TV or a
computer or a phone for a little while I
don't know why but I keep the phone one
yeah I don't know I have three of them
at my house I don't know why I'm doing
it like you think I think it's do you
have an iPhone yeah the iPhone box is
very nice it doesn't feel like a regular
cardboard yeah it has that like slow
open and close so you go this is
expensive I can hold on to this for a
little bit yeah yeah I don't know why
I'm keeping them but I I've got like
three or four of them yeah it's Dirtbag
mentality just for phones I don't have
anymore yeah exactly you don't have the
actual phone that's a good box don't
throw it out
that's all right okay what uh what
network provider do you have over there
who's yourself
Kevin Bacon is like the guy on the
adverts
that's where his career has gone
he probably cleans up good money over
there
we're at mint mobile family over here
yeah Ryan Reynolds shout out to him how
do you feel about him buying the team
I I'm desperate to get him onto our
podcast because that team is like an
hour from us no [__] so I'm constantly
hitting his PR up like you're an hour
away come and talk about this with us he
just got Caked Up he sold he's owns part
of uh mobile mint mobile which is a
prepaid uh sponsor of ours prepaid cell
service and was it just sold for like a
billion dollars or something and he owns
like 25 he owns the Gin the Gin brand
yes Aviator is it yup yes like wrexham's
like a they're like 40 is down yeah yeah
like there's a tear system with the
football new case you've got the Premier
League then the championship then League
one then League two and I think they're
in League two and they are like if they
climb which they will that they're gonna
they're gonna be everyone's second team
and everyone will have a wrexham jersey
and everyone will like when you type in
what league if autofills is wrestling
dude
there's an F there was a Netflix I don't
know it was on Netflix it was on I think
welcome to wrexham or something yeah
welcome to Rex and it was on I think FX
or something because it's always Rob
mcelhaney has a
deal with FX that he was just like oh
here's this TV show so like all
Americans are like no that'll be my team
type thing smart kids are making money
kids are making money
uh all right let's see here
uh this is from Keaton first time
posting uh
are you garbage if you wash all your
sheets towels and clothes together in
one load or do you separate them I I
just separate them by what I'm doing
after that wet you know what I mean so
I've got a machine that washes and dries
gotcha it's like a two-in-one sure so
like any t-shirts or shirts I can't wash
you can't tumble dry them because then
they'll shrink sure but like socks
underwear and like sheets and jeans let
it all roll I'll let that so you wash
your jeans and your sheets together yeah
really as long as the sheets aren't like
white right and then they go in a white
one you wash them in cold water or hot
water fancy degrees 40 degrees depending
on that's hot yeah right
yeah if he's talking Celsius yeah wait
now the way you're supposed to do what I
thought was thousand sheets are okay but
you got to do them in hot water
you're washing your jeans in hot water
kids got a tight fit over
I I I I'm letting them know I am built
really strange like I've got a I wear 32
waist jeans and then like double XL tops
like I'm built
like sure there you go
I'm built like a golf ball on a teeth
if I wash my pants in hot water that's
it they're now Rags because I'm never
squeezing it
do you guys mind if we just take a two
minute baby can I go the toilet yeah
we're chilling okay let's talk about
Adam and Eve baby oh baby I'm slipping
out of my chair right now yeah talk
about a little naughty time gank talking
about the number one adult store
delivered right to your door in discreet
packaging we're talking ticklers we're
talking oh man you don't like it knows
you don't like it in the keister you
know what I mean
they got vibrators Lubes of all kinds
ticklers whips [__] rings nipple clamps
Benoit balls butt plugs Husker dues who
don'ts crab Flappers Bug Busters just
don't forget the condoms play it safe
gang yeah there you go gang have a
little fun with yourself over there it's
20 23 what are we doing yeah fun with
yourself I'm lost by that you got a butt
plug in your mouth are you garbage
listeners get in my ears you get a very
special offer for a limited time only go
to adamandeve.com and you'll get 50 off
just about any item select your one item
at 50 off you'll also receive six free
adult DVDs plus 10 tantalizing free
mystery gifts they're giving away the
shop over there here they are uh to top
it all off they're even throwing in free
shipping on your entire order shout out
to Adam and Eve you can always feel
secure because you've always get a
90-day risk-free returns when you shop
at adamandeve.com doesn't guarantee the
satisfaction over there they can write
the pleasure town so you go to Adam and
Eve com and use code garbage at checkout
use code garbage at adamandeve.com to
save 50 on your next item do it gang do
it do it Kip let's talk about true
Classics baby true questions best
T-shirt fit in the biz I'll tell you
what that's my gold tea they get into a
true classic they go up to 3x but I'll
tell you what man they it I'm almost
there they're cut right for a bigger Jet
right I know we got a lot of heavy bike
boys out there and they wash good they
feel good man real home run with that
true Classics I'll tell you that right
now uh yeah they're designed for a man's
body you know what I mean
for dudes like me Jack diesel ex-athlete
kind of guys it's in a belly
like a fat piece of [__] true classic
tees give you both comfort and style uh
I was another one it's weird that these
brands are becoming sponsors I was using
true classic tees I saw them on
Instagram I bought a three pack of black
DS I fell in love with them you can
afford to take the entire wardrobe to
the next level of true classes
activewear denim hoodies boxers and more
no matter what the day throws at you
you'll have the right clothing for the
job with true classic you get
comfortable get comfortable and get
going upgrade your wardrobe at true
classic with Drew classic get 25 off at
trueclassic.com with our code garbage
free shipping is included on purchases
over 100 100 risk-free guarantee with a
30-day return policy you can't go wrong
they're taking care you're making you
look good maybe get you laid or
something that's trueclassic.com
code garbage it looks it looks good it's
look good feel good season get involved
now back to the show back to the show
okay let's see here this is one I ever
thought of this is from Jack what was
the speed limit on the street you grew
up with you grew up on oh that's [__]
the faster it is the trashier the
neighborhood okay so it will have been
30 miles an hour 30 miles an hour that's
respectable yeah
25 would be residential I grew up yeah
but I grew up on a cul-de-sac on a
estate
[Laughter]
it was a rough neighborhood with like
terraced houses and okay uh like I lived
a sort of halfway down a cul-de-sac okay
30 miles an hour that's good yeah yeah
55. that's tough man crossing a
four-lane highway he's trying to get a
chocolate milk
[Laughter]
that's a [__] brilliant question yeah
I never thought of that uh there was one
home run there was one time when after
my parents got divorced my dad moved to
a house like temporarily like rented a
house
and it was on a main road like proper
[__] dudes flying down the street
main road and I remember my mom be like
don't go in that goddamn yard when
you're over there at your dad's and
[__] sit down look at the window
deer crosses the road somebody peels off
yeah I think it's worth saying people
didn't obey the limit when I go back
sure like artificially it was 30 I mean
in reality it was whatever the driver
was comfortable with
there's a highway
at top of our neighborhood and during
the day when people go into work they
would cut through and cut through the
neighborhood they're cutting through the
neighborhood doing like 50 down the
street to be out there losing his
[__] mind we had a lot of like
motorbike gangs as well like really not
like
not like Harley Davidson like I'm so
like a lot of kids yeah a kids would get
like a Kawasaki and sure they'd be like
just up and down yeah like balaclavas on
and yeah yeah it's trashy yeah that's
all right sounds like a nice
neighborhood
that's good will you are you a speeder
now you got the nice car you got the
range are you you keep it tight loose I
let loose when I know that I can so like
the the highways like you're supposed to
get used to where the cameras are and if
I know I've got like 10 miles then
that's right the cameras can give you a
speeding ticket over there right that's
the only way you really got it the
police have any really just there dude
nobody's pulling you over to cameras
yeah really like you if you if a
policeman sees you yeah but they're just
not very often on the motorways and if
there is you would slow down but Yeah
man so you'll just randomly get it you
could get a ticket in the mail saying
here's a speeding ticket of yeah but you
know because you know where they are
yeah I got jammed I was in Switzerland
with my wife and we got I mean I got
like [__] 15 speeding tickets it was
like thousands of dollars too I've got
nine points I don't know how the license
system is we have a similar Point yeah
so it's 12 and you banned and you get
three for the uh like for Speed you have
nine yeah so you're right there maybe
yeah you should stop speeding
how long do they ban you for six months
fast and then it'd be a year if you got
done again a year yeah damn Brit's hold
a grudge yeah I just had to do a safe
drive got a uh ticket Upstate New York
uh speed I was flying I was doing like
90 and a 65 or 50 I think it was 55. I
got jammed up and uh they made me it was
a small town they made me do a safe
driving course oh I've done one of those
it was [__] online timed six and a
half hours so you got to sit there for
like an hour and then like it [__]
sucked so I I did that and online one of
those and I fell asleep yeah and but
it's it's still like on Zoom so like oh
really mine was just like an automated
course so I I woke up you're in the car
I'm being kicked out to the meeting
and I look I logged back in and I went
uh well and he goes there did you fall
asleep and I went yeah and he goes
you're not allowed to do that on the
course and I was like okay he goes we'll
call that a yellow card oh there you go
he said if you do it again you're out
yeah I was gonna get banned there you go
damn that's all right 8 am and I was
hungover because yeah it's also like
you're not driving it's better off doing
it there than behind the wheel you know
what I mean tell me some [__] slack
also it's just such a [__] stupid
course they're just like they're asking
you it's like you're doing like grade
one driving it's like it's so if a sign
says 40 how fast are you allowed to go
you're like 40 miles an hour like
correct oh good job yeah
it depends when the cameras are at
foreign
give me some more details
uh all right this one's from Boston
George 20 shareholder shout out to them
are you garbage if you've been manually
brushing your teeth with a broken
electronic toothbrush for over a month
not good they're not good either they're
smaller what's your toothbrush situation
same batteries
[Laughter]
um I just use a a regular a regular yeah
it's a regular guy too and because I
know I would be this guy yeah I just
won't replace it and they're not as good
as the without the the shaking and
moving those things
and the [__] heads get so old and so
disguise I remember I took it to my
buddy Pat's house and I left it there
he's like did you leave your toothbrush
in the in the bathroom like oh [__] yeah
I did and he sent me a picture he's like
you need to throw this thing out like
this is this you should not be putting
that in your mouth
it's yeah these are new batteries well
it was also back in the day when it was
like it was expensive now they're like
you know the cheaper disposable ones but
then you had to get the heads and the
heads you could only get it certain
places
[__] yeah a razor Blade's expensive
over there too uh you can get like five
uh like Gillette Mach 3s for like 10
pounds remember when they were like so
expensive they were crazy expensive
people like stealing them yeah but then
those companies like Harry's and [__]
like all those companies that did like
the dollar a month all that [__] kind of
[__] it was a wow the Mach Three Man
I remember Mach 3 was [__] huge yeah
everybody had they're just they're the
ones I used and they like but I I'll use
them twice and then throw it away and I
use the next one yeah yeah it says you
can use them you can use this for like
three months it's like no you [__]
can't kid's looking at the Docks have
you ever ever have you ever used someone
else's razor uh I've used like a
girlfriend's razor yeah yeah why not
like because like I hate this that I
know right now yeah the neck thing like
to come here today knowing this camera's
on I was like I should probably shave
this but I just didn't go and get the
thing like if I'm going on like a date
night with me misses or if I'm going out
with the guys for the Pines like I know
we're gonna be taking a group photos
just tighten it up a little bit just if
I if we're away from home in a hotel in
London and I've just sort of [__]
ways to [__] off if she's brought a
razor and I haven't got one I'll just
yeah yeah that's all right the lady ones
are nice but using somebody else's razor
as much of a disgusting dirt bag that I
am always skied me out I've I've I
didn't know when I was younger dad's
maybe I was using my brother's like
regularly
he like walked in I was shaving with he
said what the [__] are you doing he's
like have you been how long have you
been doing like I don't know like two
years [__] Dirtbag I remember like he
would use it what do I have goes through
blades every two weeks he would use it
and then I would just use it like right
it would still be like wet and I'd be
like this doesn't feel right but oh dude
I didn't know man I was young these
races like that down oh do you trim I've
I used I I mean I've done uh now I'm a
manscaped man if you're asking
[Laughter]
isn't that a lake on the moon
didn't Magellan get hung up there one
time holy [__] that is the boner with
that section yeah yeah yeah so I use
manscape there and then around me balls
and stuff but then sometimes I'll take
the Mac because like I get the
occasional hair on me oh yeah for sure
on the shaft yeah just occasional like
it's not like it doesn't look like
[__] Wolverine but like it's just
like
eyelashes it's just every now and then
it's just like
you should pluck that it'll take longer
to get oh that's gonna hurt dude I'm not
plucking anything [__] that out of
there
that's a screamer
I'm not plucking because
that's the greatest sentence ever said
I'm not plucking me [__]
I don't care for those tweezers
uh yeah did your uh did you guys dad
teach you how to shave or you have to
figure it out shave your pubes
what you're going to want to do is pluck
me [__]
no no one taught me anything ever they
were just like Mike no one talk to me
they just said go I at one point I was
using a blade and cream on my ball sack
I think I was nicking myself up pretty
bad I think my dad did but he shaved
those guys shaved every day they shaved
different like I gotta be real it didn't
it didn't translate well
he showed me how to do with a Bowie
knife yeah she this is a man shapes tell
me how I shake
any life lessons from your parents
instilled on you
um did you have the birds and the bees
talk so my mom tried to have that with
me and I told her to go away okay
because my mom and dad had uh split up
they broke up and uh I mean dad was
always around but there was like a three
or four month period where we didn't see
much of them because him and my mum's
relationship had become so difficult and
then it was fine after that but in that
period I remember I was in the bath I
mean mum come in and was like I just you
know there's things your Dad should be
to and I just went into and I just don't
yeah just get the [__] out say that I'm
in the bath yeah
yeah I just jerked off I know what's
going on I got it
it's funny have you ever been caught by
your parents uh masturbating
one time I did so that we we had this
thing in the UK for a while called Lads
mags okay so they were like soft porn so
it wasn't like um Hustler it wasn't like
the sure thing more
Playboys or something subtle yeah well
like dinner or something like that
going for a walk in the park it's a guy
picking her up there was one called zoo
and one called Nuts magazine and I would
get both of them every week and then
what I done with them I used to keep
them under the bottom drawer of my
bedside table I know that moved very
well of course and one one time I came
home from school and my mum and dad had
done like a spring cleaning of the whole
house and they'd like move things around
in my room so they'd obviously picked it
up and there was just nothing there and
uh then I was playing table tennis with
me that we had a table tennis table in
the garden and uh I was playing with
them nice and he goes so I found your
magazines and I was like yep thought you
would have just uh throw them away
yeah it's your serve shut up
and he asked me who's been buying them
and I was like I was buying them myself
you can buy those ones they will give
you them oh where are you buying them
yourself yeah what were they called
again
oh yeah
Lads Max is nice yeah it sounds refined
Jen yeah guy smoking a pipe or something
that ain't too shabby like a little soft
quartz nice
sure hey I don't discriminate you know
what I mean I like a nice story in a in
a video as well I need a good storyline
you can just click it and have them just
be [__] chased away no never I gotta
know why the plumber has his pants off
what happened here
[Laughter]
yeah you gotta whine and dine me a
little bit you can't just [__] bend
me over and go to town excuse me sir I'm
a lady uh all right this one's from
Jonathan I saw this recently by you on
the road ever use an ironing board as a
TV as a TV tray or table yeah really
I'll put my laptop on it put Netflix on
the laptop and and then use it if I'm in
a hotel that's like [__] Ian doesn't
have Netflix on the TV like I'll use my
laptop as the TV absolutely you get the
item but out you put it near the bed
yeah that's trash I think that's just
genius will you eat off the table you
eat off use it as a table to eat I don't
think I've ever done that well maybe I
have like stood up like drunk also my
favorite move when I'm in a hotel if
they've got a bathtub is I'll get in the
bath and I'll put the laptop on the
toilet seat and watch something while
I'm in the bath well you'll take a bath
in a hotel yeah that's pretty wild
that's not the cleanest thing
especially if I was just doing it that's
rough I got news for you that's trash
that's one of the questions we asked
have you ever taken a bath in a hotel
not in like a luxury hotel with a woman
and Bubbles and everything you'll just
take it you'll just draw a bath and sit
if I was going to Bath and it looks
clean to the naked eye
girl no man can I say this like swimming
in the Nile the TV at hotels has really
gone downhill it's just [__] garbage
I guess they I guess they assume you're
just watching [__] on your phone or your
laptop but man it's a real tough look
you get like two stations one of them is
the [__] hotel station do they do it
where you have to like jump through the
menus and [__] it's like it's not you
can't just turn it on and go yeah it's
it's like the buttons don't work it
[__] sucks man yeah but a lot of
hotels are sort of having
like they they're getting sort of
makeovers and stuff and they're getting
bigger better TVs and smart TVs uh-huh
[__] it's good yeah so what I'm in here
has got like Netflix on the TV really
you have to use your own passcode yeah
oh see I don't like that but I'll log
out before I leave
[Laughter]
it's not your bank account I'm not
leaving that for the next game they know
something I don't like it yeah I
couldn't do that if they should if they
should just have it why can't the hotel
just have you have to have an account in
every room oh yeah that'd be [__]
you'd be spending fifty thousand dollars
a month in [__] Netflix what are you
a boy scout what are you talking about
you never shared your NFI but still even
two or three
you can't have unlimited 900 rooms yeah
Hyatt can't pay for one [__]
subscription for every [__] hotel for
me hey police picking seven bucks a
month we got 14 000 people
that's all right uh wait Moneyball this
one's just nuts this is for Molly ten
dollar homie never had one red uh
uh is my my dad would cut the toes off
his tennis shoes to make open-toed
sandals he left the soul intact just cut
the upper leather part off yeah that's
that's that's hillbilly [__] I guess
that's not I mean that's crazy that used
to be hillbilly [__] but now he could
charge like three hundred dollars sure
yeah it's probably now it's like this
[__] you know
yeah that's what that [__] is changing
well this [__] changing idiots
poverty Chic is like a thing oh dude
it's crazy you see people on them like
it's like dude I popped into a thrift
store I was killing time like a V
they're called it a vintage store it was
a [__] you know Buffalo Exchange it
wasn't Buffalo we saw one in the village
uh on like uh four straight or whatever
I've been shot down at a Buffalo
Exchange you have Buffalo Exchange over
there so it's like it's it's like what
Kevin's talking about it's like nicer uh
like a nicer thrift store but you can
exchange your stuff you can go in there
with your old cools like higher end
stuff yeah yeah they shot me down on a
pair of sweatpants
are you trying to buy them or sell them
try to give it back
I'm just trying to make a move
trying to get liquid over here liquid
ate some funds I don't think any F cash
out my sweatpants fund I don't think any
phrases had a bigger glow up in the past
like two decades than the phrase second
hand oh yeah like and in a second I was
saying it's like oh that's vintage yeah
I know just someone owned it that's what
I'm saying I walked into this dude it
was like a jack I was like oh this is a
cool jacket it was like I don't know
from the 90s or something it was like I
don't know some sort of [__] letter
what Leatherman or members only or
something I'm like oh it's cool it's
like [__] 380 300 like [__] get
out of here with that [__] yikes not
today
not today look at these members only
know uh get them jackets behind Tebow
and make a couple of bucks on them yeah
there's my [__] beard none of them
fit that was a problem I was buying
these [__] vintage beer jackets
online like it's a triple XL then you
buy it but it's from the 80s so like
people aren't that fat back then a
double XL was way different in 88 than
it is today and apparently I'm like a
9xl in the 80s this is this Bear's
jacket's an XL and it's like a child
small dude it's a good job I'd be like
nine people in the 80s
you know what's funny is I pulled that
that red one out of uh out of the bag
yesterday or a couple days ago to put it
on the on the on the rack and I was like
God damn this is what he squeezing into
no no that one yeah that one came out of
the box I didn't even attend sleep that
night I didn't it's like a toddler I
didn't attempt to put it on I just put
it back in the box it came with it and
shoved it in my closet my wife's been
begging me to get it out of the car yeah
Buffalo Exchange yeah there you go if
you want uh this one's from Ryan is it
garbage if you smoke weed out of
something not meant for it me and my
buddy once rolled a joint out of a
receipt paper
but yeah you shouldn't be smoking
receipts you smoke weed no I I never did
but I did recently I went to Amsterdam
with a cash boys there you go
um I had a [__] great time really I
like me and so me and Carl both had very
different experiences but like on a
similar level so I just went I just
couldn't stop laughing for like hours
sure and he went whiter than I've ever
seen anyone go hey he had to go to sleep
did he does he smoke weed a lot no
neither of us do so that was a good
thing for our podcast viewers they were
like of course the two lads who don't do
it are gonna need a property over again
Amsterdam there was so I I was trying to
I've seen the footage I don't remember
all of it but like I'm trying to explain
to people that I don't understand how my
hands work so I'm like why can I do that
like what what how is it working what's
happening between here and here that is
making me be able to do that and then we
went to a Chinese restaurant you know
like the boss boy who's collecting all
the plates sure I was saying that he has
I was screaming at the top of me is this
God's got the best job on the [__]
planet he can just eat people's leftover
food
he doesn't need to pay for food the
hungriest guy in the world
this bubble gupper rolling on his seat
did you eat it or did you smoke it or it
was in like a big um bag thing oh like
the volcano the volcano yeah wow you
never sounded more like a cop right now
by the way
did you eat it we used to smoke
exclusively and we knew it was bad for
you out of a Coke can you take a Coke
can and you Dent it an aluminum can and
then crack I didn't think yeah no you
also smoke crack that way
yeah you're right
it's not exclusively for dirtbags who
smoke weed he may or may not have been
smoking crack no in high school we we
did weed and we knew that of course we
did we yeah who's who's the cop now dork
where did you score your stuff
I think sharp is going to poke me
you've been drinking tonight sir no we
used to we used to do the Coke cans and
we knew I remember like you see how you
get old silence is really yeah if I get
what are you gonna do yeah we used to uh
I remember people would say you smoke
out if you smoked out of like metal they
said it would give your lungs arthritis
or something I was like 10. I made a lot
of aluminum foil bowls in my day Tenors
wrapping around wrapping around a pencil
and then pull it out and then and then
also also good for crack yeah that's
also cracked I think you're a crackhead
I am not you guys know when you're
smiling docks what are you talking about
uh do you ever need beef with any
neighbors or anything like that uh no at
my at my building as vet I know you had
the issue with the guy with the with
taking your trash cans and [__] oh they
moved me bins which is it was another
home run of a home he moved me bins but
that's a new spot at the new spot no
troubles right no because we've got like
a trash shoes so like you don't even see
your bins
it didn't have to be with the bins
anybody and it's it's also like the
Airbnb and a lot of the rooms because
like that they can't fill them tourists
and stuff like that coming in do you
like that it's got to be not great I
just don't I don't know what to say like
I just if I'm in my apartment then I'm
in the apartments and if I'm I was a
mouse like I'm not in the communal area
there's a lot shots well you do airbnbs
on the road or do hotels or what do you
do what do you like what do you prefer
because we flip-flop a little bit over
here I prioritize hotels just because I
I trust the system more I don't just
disagree I mean you know what you're
getting yeah you're paying a corporation
not some [__] guy yeah it's just it
feels safer I don't know why
um I've asked depending on sales can I
get a bus for my tour oh I've asked Live
Nation uh promoting it like instead of
doing hotels and hiring a car again you
get a tall boss with a bed in it you got
a shower somewhere though yeah they have
it on it on the bus oh really that's a
proper tour bus yeah
wait so in your your tour now they drive
you you have a driver to the from no so
we would just go some budget and I was
like I want to get
um this guy's cool I want a support act
on every show uh-huh um and I want me
videographer at every show
um and I'll pay them day rates obviously
but also I'm gonna ask them to do the
driving like I hate doing long drives
that's like so the sports have to be
told you're on this fee but you're also
doing the driving to the shows
um and I was like but that's three
hotels a day like that's why we started
doing airbnbs we travel with five of us
between me Foley Toby Luke and our
opener plus you get to goof around more
when it's an Airbnb yeah yeah but I just
because of that I was like is it more
cost effective to get a Boston pay three
expensive I think they really are crazy
but like if because the tour is going to
hire a card as well they're gonna hire a
car for the tour out of the budget and
then they're gonna pay for three hotels
at that point it's like it doesn't get
there yeah it probably will get towards
similar prices yeah it's just cool let's
have a boss it's fun dude we did it we
did it with Bert for two or three days
it was [__] fantastic I don't think
they showered on the bus though you'd
always want to get a hotel just to
freshen up a little bit right were they
showering on there
will be they there is a shower on there
I don't know if they did though I think
well I no we showered at the venue the
one time when we got there and then we
showed they did have us they had a hotel
room not to sleep in though you would
just stay on the bus the whole time you
would shower do everything in there
that's what I assumed but maybe you get
you're informing me stuff that I need to
be evaluate I don't know though yeah
I would love a [__] ayg tour bus
putting Across America breaking down
you gotta stay on brain baby yellow
school bus
uh all right let's see let's do one or
two more here then we gotta wrap it up
there gang uh this one I never thought
about this is for Matt
is it garbage to open presents at the
restaurant table when it's someone's
birthday no that's normal I think it's
kind of normal but I could see how it
could be portrayed a little trashy we
always did it I feel like a bigger as a
bigger thing too though I mean if it was
just my immediate family we would do it
at the house you're supposed to open the
presents in front of the person who gave
you it sure like so if they're not going
to be coming home with you you've got to
do it at the dining table
yes that does make sense in a bag with a
little paper I think would be all right
are you still getting birthday presents
like no so we like me me girlfriend got
me a lot of really great uh well
Christmas is what I normally do it's
like I'll have my dad and me brother
over for food we'll get all each other
presents get me girlfriend quite a bit
and then the podcast team we all do
Christmas presents as well so what we do
is we film just before Christmas we did
the have a weird Christmas
Christmas I cook dinner for everyone oh
no we didn't do it in the studio we did
it in so in my building
there's a communal kitchen or whatever
yeah so I just hired that for the night
and we filmed in there I did dinner for
everyone we all did presents and then we
released that at 6am Christmas morning I
was like if you're alone at Christmas
spend it with us Ah that's funny he's a
good [__] this Adam Rose
eyg Christmas if you're alone yeah
that's all right all right we gotta wrap
it up gang buddy this has been so fun I
love you man thank you so much
congratulations on all your success
thank you very much we got your two
specials out two specials we're starting
anything else you want to focus on yeah
if you're over in the UK tour starts in
October it's just adamro.com UK you can
get all the shows there the two specials
that have gone out imperius is my last
stand-up tour from last year it's just a
traditional hour to stand up my sort of
stereotypical bits juicy is one long
story and uh I have to say for legal
reasons it's fictional but I think that
that's been the most well received very
fictional
yeah that's been the most well received
bit of work I've ever put out awesome I
have had thousands of like big paragraph
messages about to go and [__] so I I
didn't realize it was going to have that
effect and I knew I was the most proud
of that that I'd ever been of anything
else but like it's it's really come
across so if you if you want to watch
anything go and watch Adam Road juicy
it's on the have a Word podcast YouTube
channel thank you brother love it
congratulations
uh guys we're also all over the road uh
shows are selling out we're adding
second shows uh get those tickets before
they are gone uh thank you so much we
love you gang we love you we'll see you
next week